now on to our first topic Britain's role
in jihad in northern Iraq this week we
saw a shocking video coverage of an
apparently British man out to behead an
American journalist it was shocking but
for those who've been following it's not
surprising in his cover story this week
Douglas Murray and says how this should
be seen is a logical extension of what's
been going on for a long long time in
Britain the steady radicalization and
our ability to export jihad better than
anybody else in the West
sure as mayor is King's College academic
and one of Britain's leading authorities
in radicalization Douglas is a new piece
that resistant even the first time that
a Brit with London accents been behind
it beheading misses sort of thing has
happened before
yes it's not amazingly enough it's not
even the first time the London born Brit
or london-based Brit has been involved
in the murder of an American journalist
in 2002 as I may see my piece
the London born and Landon School of
Economics graduate my Sheikh was behind
the kidnap and beheading of the Wall
Street Journal reporter Daniel Pearl
there are many other cases in the
interim of Brits going abroad fighting
in a range of conflict zones sometimes
bringing that back here but it's part of
a pattern that's why I say it is on the
one hand obviously incredibly shocking
and yet anyone who's pay paid any
attention over the last decade should
realize it isn't surprising well sure as
you been paying close even following all
this right from the very start what do
you see happening here uh it has Britain
got had a massive supply of jihadis
who've just migrated or is this war
having the radicalizing effect on people
who are halfway there already I think if
it's a bit of both really there are a
number of people for whom this is the
fight they've wanted to have they've had
a long-standing history of radical
activism
in this country they're the people we
see burning poppies outside the American
Embassy and doing all that kind of
activity traditionally this is the fight
they've wanted to have
and it's provided them with that
opportunity but on the other side
there's a whole bunch of other people
who have gone it is from a standing
position they were not radicalist before
but through what they've seen over the
last few years they decided that this is
something they want to be part of they
want to go out there and to build this
Islamic state they regard it as a utopia
and frankly they think they're winning
right now and that momentum is
propelling them to go out there and the
Brits that were seeing involved in this
all right I mean there's a striking
number of them the figures range
anything from 500 to up to 1500 and but
are they actually getting to senior
positions within Isis or are they just
being used to present to go in front of
the YouTube video camera because that's
the way Isis likes to do social media to
use Western voices to talk to Westerners
well the point is the British fighters
out there I'm not in the senior
leadership positions the ones in senior
leadership are overwhelmingly Iraqi and
then the others who occupy more military
tactical roles are those who are coming
from countries where they've had direct
combat experience so a lot of the
Chechens and fighters on the Balkans who
of course have had their own experience
fighting out there but we've been down
to the border areas of Syria and Turkey
talking to fighters met some foreign
fighters as well but spoken to a lot of
people out there who are Syrian
themselves who've experienced this war
and a lot of them told us during our
fieldwork that they regard the British
fighters out there to be amongst some of
the most extreme and vicious fighters
who have come into this conflict the
most extreme and vicious fighters and
Douglas isn't it I mean you know it's
not as if Britain is Chechnya you've got
people who have been living in complete
peace and security why should it be but
they go into a theater of war and then
rank amongst the most vicious fighters
with frenzy I mean the work that Shiraz
and his colleagues have done in bringing
a lot of this to light has been
invaluable because we know we do now
know more now about the mindsets of
these people and I think at any point
before it is a whole range of things as
sheer as just mentioned among other
things the opportunity to kind of have a
cause the opportunity to be involved in
something they think as being a
potentially winning cause so give your
life meaning or something
it's partly that it's very striking as
well the video of those who were
recruited it from Cardiff video came out
with it last month over the Cardiff
Fighters we've gone over to Syria you
know it's all that rhetoric of you know
think about your life is it is it a
meaningful existence is it is it an
important existence and and these people
in a way I mean I suppose one has to
separate out on one hand of course there
is a very clear religious ideology that
they believe they are propelled by but
there is also the as it were sort of
angst of wanting a cause and wanting to
find meaning and and and so on which
they have in common with a lot of young
people and of course in particular
always a lot of other young men the
sheer as this is one of the very few
Wars were actually able to follow in
social media because the combatants are
tweeting I imagine of course these are
self selecting guys it doesn't give us a
genuine cross-section of it but em can
you say more about just why this has
become such an important tool for Isis
their rather professional they're using
or working with organizations like vice
news for example who produced a stunning
hour-long documentary which must have
been done with the obvious not just with
a corporation I dare say it was done
after some censorship from Isis - but is
this part of their strategy to actually
try to shock and awe the whole world
with these videos I think when we
consider what Isis or the Islamic state
is doing right now it's important to see
where they've come from al-qaeda had
traditionally mastered propaganda and
understood how to get its message out
there the Islamic state is really an
ultra form of this it has understood how
to capitalize and they utilize social
media allowing its fighters to tweets to
spread messages it has force multipliers
all around the world there's this huge
community of people who sit in the West
or in other parts of the world who are
cheering on and supporting everything
this group does and so the level of
support that Isis is able to generate
for its activity is phenomenal really
and you follow the board as well do you
we follow the supporters but we follow
the fighters very very closely and we're
now following over 500 accounts and
a lot of social science data shows that
actually 1201 individual account it
doesn't give you much information but
when you begin to bring together a group
of people self selecting though they are
you can begin to make some very accurate
conclusions about their religious
beliefs about their political
affiliations what they're aspiring to
and unfortunately what we've seen now in
Syria particularly the last two three
months since the announcement of the
Declaration of the Caliphate it's a real
hardening of attitude a real sense of
callousness and brutality that they were
trying to cover up before they're
bringing a lot back out into the open
right and Douglas why Britain never
there are Muslims all over Europe and
there's not much sign or impressed shows
you can tell us that there is all sort
of French daddies or Italian genji
Hadees what is it about British and
jihadis that seems so distinctive well I
mean I sure would agree that in a way
it's not absolutely distinctive to
Britain most Western countries have a
version of this at the moment has been
significant soul-searching and
hand-wringing in Australia in recent
months over Australians we've gone out
to fight we have seen the same from
Canada from the US from Denmark from
Scandinavia and from France and Italy
and so on so it is a problem that a lot
of countries have got at the moment I
think one of the important things though
if I just say about this and something I
tried to bring out on the piece is that
there is a terrible tendency in Britain
at the moment has been going off for a
long time to regard everything in this
part of the world as being something to
do with 2003 something to do with Tony
Blair I used to do my George Bush that
the basis of Britain's desire to keep on
returning and picking at the scab of the
debate over Iraq in a way is clouding
our ability to see what is actually
happening there at the moment the is
this because of an intervention or not
and one of the things I say in the piece
which I just really stress and think is
important thing to bring out is to an
extent this is really not about us it's
not about Britain of course there are
parts of it that are but to a great
extent it isn't and let me put it this
way in the 1990s this country did not
intervene in the Balkans and a
generation of British P
while others went out to join the jihad
in the Balkans in the 2000s we did
intervene in Afghanistan we did
intervene in Iraq and to an extent we
created another part of a generation of
jihad
we haven't intervened in Syria and by
not intervening again there is an
element of people going out and another
jihad so one of the things I really
think that people in Britain should
think about in this is is this actually
because of us intervening or not
intervening or is it possible and I
would submit it is that there is a
hatred and a momentum and an ideology in
the world of the moment that is very
powerful to some people and which would
exist whether we existed or not whether
labour was in power a coalition
government of Conservatives and Lib Dems
whoever is in power this is actually
about more than us I think just to build
on that point the ideology that a group
like the Islamic state is offering is
incredibly seductive to young men who
are fully integrated as Douglas was
saying for the searching for identity
searching for cos and they're coming
along and saying look we have a panacea
to the problems of the Muslim world and
there are many problems but we could
uproot all of this by creating this
Islamic state and guess what we've done
it and we're holding territory large
amounts of territory in Syria and Iraq
and we're being allowed to do it
effectively and so these guys find that
idea very very powerful and I think it
also goes back to something which
Douglas talks about in his piece which
is that there is a long history a long
tradition of very radical Islam in parts
of British Muslim life in this country
and so even though a lot of the sort of
caricature or headline sort of preachers
may not be here anymore
Omar Bakri Mohammed's gone Hamza has
gone and various other clerics are no
longer here that doesn't matter a
certain idea has been established so
there is a generation of Muslims a
minority but nonetheless the generation
who do believe that a very austere very
narrow dogmatic Caliphate is exactly
what the Muslim world needs and so when
they see this taking place now they're
saying well this is what we've been told
about this is what we've been waiting
for and if they go and how do you notice
Brits being more disproportionately
presence in Iraq
of European countries so we've collected
figures from around Europe North America
and Australia about who's been going the
numbers from Britain are high but
they're selling not the highest from
Europe we estimate about two thousand
total roughly just over two thousand
have gone from Europe as a whole when
you wait the numbers by the size of
Muslim community in those countries a
Belgium at is that the highest it's the
first Scandinavian countries also ranked
very highly Britain it's certainly top
five in France of course is also very
highly represented and the point to make
is a lot of these guys earlier one if
they went in the end of 2012 but aside
of 2013 they were joining some of the
other groups as well today we're going
to the groups like a harem or lesser
known organizations now people are by
large more that's exclusively going to
join the Islamic state and Douglas the
Prime Minister has come back from
Cornwall to look at all this but what
exactly can he do is I mean can we link
this to any sort of you know home office
border security issue
Evette Cooper today is from a Labour
Party is talking about stuff and in
control orders being connected to it is
there anything which David Cameron has
done in the last few years or could do
now that can make any difference to this
well there are things that could be done
there are things that could be done I
think on the ground in Syria and in Iraq
and I certainly think that unless
there's a fair attitude towards the
situation could be employed however I
think that the political point-scoring
of a vet coop on this is is is rather
unpleasant to see really and sure as
finally and you mean be following with
500 accounts are they growing although
do you get the sense of momentum is
building quickly here we saw a lot of
momentum towards the end of last year
then it's actually slowed down at the
start of this year because of the
infighting it's certainly picking up
again and not least because of the
declaration of the Caliphate by the
Islamic state and that's giving people a
sense of momentum now who want to go and
be the most effect with this video house
all the sort of people you're looking at
now but you are still in Britain would
this be the sort of thing that would
actually inspire them to go out there do
you think oh but surely they would be
shocked at the beheading of
a blameless American it is very
difficult to explain to ordinary members
of society that people who are sitting
in the West in this country who are
supporting the Islamic state when they
saw what happened to James Foley are
cheering that and are embracing that we
have a lot of software that monitors
sort of sentimentalities and all these
kinds of things on social media there is
without a doubt a huge community of
people many of them resident in the West
and in this country too who were
cheering and celebrating what happened
last night to James Foley and so in that
sense actually it doesn't put them off
at all they will celebrate anything they
regard as humiliating the West or being
a catalyst of the West and of course
that's precisely the terms in which that
video was framed